hey 42 here in 1859 Charles Robert
Darwin published on the Origin of
Species which contained the most
compelling evidence to ever support the
theory of evolution since then darwin's
theory has been widely accepted within
the scientific community if Darwin is to
be believed it took the human race 6
million years to evolve from chimpanzees
to modern-day Homo sapiens but will
humans ever evolve again or has the
human race reached its physical and
mental peak let's find out many skeptics
argue that humans have reached their
evolutionary P because evolution is
about two species adapting itself to its
environment but humans have learned to
adapt the environment to Wars for
example instead of the body having to
adapt to living in a cold climate we
instead build a house around us and
install heating and there you go instant
warmth with no fur fur evolution
needed thousands of years ago humans
evolved to run faster and see further
away in the distance to Adel's when
hunting animals but now we buy our food
from the shop and we don't need to run
anywhere because we have cars we also
don't need to see long distances because
we spend all day staring at computer
screens so based on this the rules of
evolution states that humans have no
further needs to evolve and therefore
will never evolve again but also there's
the issue with modern medicine as
wonderful as it is it does prohibit
evolution before modern medicine the
weak would die out and only the
strongest and fittest would pass on
their genes to the next generation
however today weak individuals who
previously wouldn't have survived a
disease or an injury now survived thanks
to modern medicine the downside of this
is that they're weak genes get passed on
just as much as those with strong genes
this essentially makes a theory of
survival of the fittest null and void in
the modern day
eh but all that sounds awfully boring
some leading anthropologists entertain
another school of thought which is far
more titillating they believe that there
are ways we can and will evolve in the
modern world and the result will be
quite shocking and it's not your
speculation either there is hard proof
that humans are still evolving a study
by the evolutionary biology team it's
Yale University revealed that due to the
size and the shape of their ovaries
shorter and slightly plumper women tend
to have more children than their taller
skinnier counterparts this is an example
of evolution happening right under our
noses many scientists agree that if we
do evolve in the near future the first
thing that will change will be the size
of our brains the biggest evolutionary
changes have come from the brain such as
abstract thinking which led us to new
inventions and of course language so it
makes sense that in our modern world
where information rules the brain will
be the next thing to evolve what can our
brains physically get any larger
well the biggest factor that has limited
human brain size up until now has been
the birthing process baby's heads must
be able to fit through the birth canal
which has stopped their brains from
growing any larger in the womb but with
the massive rise in cesarean sections in
recent years this could all be about to
change
today over 50% of babies in China are
delivered by a c-section and of course a
c-section means no more limits on the
size a baby's head can grow some
anthropologists believe this growing
c-section trend could give way to babies
being born with increasingly larger
brains and heads in the future some
theorize that in a few generations down
the line humans could have huge heads
and scrawny bodies just like aliens in
science fiction films but what about our
physical appearance surely there's no
further need for humans to evolve in
this respect
well there isn't a need in terms of
survival what scientists think in the
future we will evolve to look different
alas this is because more so than ever
before
males are choosing their sexual partners
based on looks and intelligence levels
as opposed to their ability to produce
healthy offspring therefore more
attractive and more intelligent females
will get more chances to reproduce and
pass on their genes the consequence of
this is that the human race will
ultimately evolve to be smarter and well
just generally more pleasant to look at
this type of selection based on
attractiveness does of course happen
with both genders but research has shown
it's considerably more prominent amongst
males this is a newly emerging
evolutionary phenomenon which scientists
refer to as artificial selection as
opposed to natural selection because
it's no longer mother nature and our
environment that chooses how we evolve
it's now humans themselves who are
deciding which genes get passed on and
which don't
when natural selection isn't dead just
yet our environment still poses a
massive risk to us as the population of
the human race increases and we become a
more globalized community traveling back
and forth to every corner of the planet
we are spreading pathogens easier and
quicker than ever before biologists
predict that we're going to get a lot
more virus epidemics in the coming years
and huge chunks of the population with
weak immune systems and poor access to
modern health care will be killed up the
result of this is that humans will
evolve
do you have stronger immune systems
naturally and become less dependent on
medicine and the global life expectancy
will rise but changes such as this will
take thousands of years before we really
start to notice the difference
so yes humans are still only in their
infancy when it comes to evolution
there's a lot more weird and wacky
mutations to come in the future
but there's one thing you can guarantee
the human race a million years from now
will look remarkably more different and
function in completely different ways
than they do today thank to the view
subscribe for more thoughty2